yo tout le monde sait ce quiz y ait
aujourd'hui est un grand jour puisque
j'exécute vaud c'est dur à dire maman
est aujourd'hui est un grand jour car
j'ai effectué de vos ordres pour la
quatrième fois boit de l'eau par l'onu
voilà ça s'appelle se noyer est ce que
tu veux que je me nomme en direct de
cette chaise et bahia aucun problème je
relève le défi en bus c'est pareil que
quand on prend de l'eau par le nsa
hydrate bien à pau tout ça alors êtes
vous prêts on est bien d'accord
s'appelle se noyer mais on va tester
j'ai cru mourir
j'ai vraiment cru mourir mais pendant
moins d'une seconde mais c'était
vraiment je sais ce qu'ils appellent à
mort voilà mais je vous le dirai pas
parce que j'aime bien ce mystère oh la
vache
merci jean high five puis rentrer ton
corps dans un sweat shirt en faisant
passer les jambes par les manches c'est
quelque chose que j'ai toujours voulu
faire c'est totalement faux et avaient
une photo avec ce tweet qui m'a
grandement inspiré je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bordel et 5 rap je sais pas un poisson
j'ai trop vu tester va tester et voilà
on garde bon directeur du voile comme ça
bonjour je voudrais en manche collé les
chouquettes s'il vous plaît enfin félix
disparition voilà c'est à ne pas
reproduire ses choix che ce bruit qui se
passe est un problème touche mettre de
l'eau dans le démon gars essaye de faire
le grand écart alors il est vrai que
j'ai fait à gisborne vous savez tous
meilleurs je vous l'avais dit va tenter
grandi cas ça fait extrêmement longtemps
que j'ai pas tenter leur personnes se
moquent le grand écart de jambes je
tiens regardez ce perpendiculaire je le
tiens mais alors le vrai grand écart on
tente [ __ ] je suis à mon max chamond
match young ha ha
ça fait tellement mal [ __ ] voilà je le
tiens ou pas est ce que je le tiens et
là tu vois je vais tomber non ça
n'arrivera pas j'ai pris des mesures de
sécurité en fait non il n'y a aucune
mesure de sécurité
je peux tomber à tout moment au plus
tard voilà donc ce n'est besoin de
sécuriser quelque chose après moi vous y
voyez stade efficace vraiment mais j'ai
une mission ou pas bon turn donne for
what are faire s'occuper dikalo début un
mec bouche bizarrement puis sautez pète
le sol c'est ça fait un job ce match
non il faut arrêter avec les dogues ce
match voilà moi je vais inventer un truc
c'est le smash daube pour la nuit ces
donnes tu vois tu vois bien ce match
dans sa gueule mois encore
dessiner un serpent pour tenir compagnie
à ta girafe baissé mais qu'elle se soit
un petit peu seul mais souvent je chante
en pleurer derrière moi en vidéo le ser
comprend vite j insiste il prend vie tu
vas être la plus heureuse du monde
regardons un peu ce magnifique cette
[ __ ] c'est assez fort rivière comme et
ressemblent ces mêmes que toi il a juste
pas le corps il se passe un truc entre
les deux on va les laisser passer un
truc entre vraiment mais remet ça peut
intéresser des prostituées toit pour
draguer ton chat écoute j'ai pris en
flagrant délit jumbo avec plein de petit
chat femmes bon c'est un peu bizarre
comme phrase
donc je pense que mon charmant
prostituées nour absolument aucun effet
sur huit modèles dont une femme
séduisante bonne qui voit la bastide
jean bognard regard comme je suis séduit
de par mon incroyable physique tu pars
en courant
tétouan pour voir ce que ça procure
comme sensation
je me suis vraiment mis un coup violent
là par contre assez remisé dans place
j'arrête youtube
je travaille dans un garage refait la
cène du seigneur des anneaux vous ne
passerez pas avec jumbo jumbo est très
bonne
acteur il a joué devant les gros films
hollywoodiens basse et aux ados c'était
lui gandalf
à
et voilà jean se dit enfin de soi autant
d'épisodes 4 c'est assez court désolé
j'ai pas eu énormément de temps pour le
tour de mes fils falcon qui vous aura
fait plaisir et si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à aimer john dahl voilà
c'est john bocco en effet mondiale fait
ça c'est nul c'est nul c'est nul c'est
bête
mais ça vous regardez la vidéo je
souhaite un bon début de vacances de
noël c'est vrai c'est là c'est
maintenant que ça vous fait bien plaisir
ont surtout retrouvé notre nouvelle
vidéo merci d'avoir regardé je viens de
le dire et on s'en fout tient tout bis
[Applaudissements]